[Musique]
bienvenue dans ce nouveau numéro de paf
où nous allons passer en revue
l'actualité avec jean baptiste du club
bonjour vous enseigner à l'université de
versailles saint quentin
jean-patrice ça va bien ça va très bien
il vous est un pécheur ça va commencer à
savoir la jeunesse et de fraîcheur s'est
pas séparé du jeu on est tous pêcheurs
mustapha la ba oui où j'étais parti vous
appelez moustapha lô jean baptiste parce
que peut-être que nous staff et un rétro
qui fait honte à la france mais il me
présentait comme jean-philippe vous êtes
vous êtes pharmacien vous êtes président
honoraire du football club de trappes d
absolument vous êtes donc à des
présidents de pharma citoyens que ce
soir c'est quand même ce que ce qui va
m'intéresser dans les prochaines années
donc je vous le dis il ya un des
trappistes on peut dire les plus
célèbres sans être moine
on va dire que je suis actif sur la
ville et donc par définition je
rencontre beaucoup de gens et beaucoup
de trappes lice en particulier donc
connu de ces gens là qui je travaille
que ses besoins
florence mercadex choqué bon je vous
n'êtes jamais à la cour de versailles et
jean charles lajoie denis vous êtes
éditeur qui s'est bien juré des tories
travail
alors il ya évidemment beaucoup de
sujets dans l'actualité on peut on peut
peut-être commencé alors c'est vrai
qu'on a beaucoup parlé ça fatigue un peu
mais enfin la polémique autour d'eric
zemmour qui publie son dernier livre
destin français avait déjà suicide
français site français d'annoncés la
femme de la france et de république dans
d'un destin français et d'un os
d'imminence d'une guerre civile
quelqu'un qui a un peu peur de tout ce
qui se passe les de tout ce qui nous
entoure
et puis il ya cette polémique aussi sur
les lieux à la télévision avec une
chroniqueuse qui s'appelle as pas de
souci à qui il aurait dit voilà vous
devriez vous appelez corinne parce que
il a dit blé absa tous et c'est un
prénom qui fait honte à la france mais
il ya quand même une chose c'est que
zemmour est bien évidemment pas connu
pour sa son sens de la mesure il est
toujours dans l'outrance en plus hardis
son jeu versé c'est consubstantiel yeux
c'est vrai substantielle de l'émission
aussi si on est mièvre
on va pas chez ardisson
l'idée de faire du lycée de faire du
buzz et faire du buzz après moi j'ai pas
du tout de faire l'exégèse d'eric
zemmour mais c'est pas complètement
idiot non pas que 900 tenadi mais c'est
vrai que si on a un prénom extrêmement
marqué c'est pas c'est pas une preuve de
volonté d'intégration de la part des
parents etc
alors après ce que c'est bien ou pas de
s'intégrer oui après donc c'est le débat
sur l'assimilation à l'intégration ville
est plutôt pour l'assimilation
il pose la question c'est sûr que quand
on s'appelle hapsatou passé c'est plus
compliqué dans la vie peut-être au
départ que si on s'appelle corinne comme
il le dit voilà après après kevin c'est
pas compliqué mais ici d'abord kevin
c'est extrêmement compliqué on sait très
bien que sur les prénoms brandon kevin
etc tous les services qu'ils aient des
races te disent ils n'engagent pas des
fins ils ont ils ont du mal que tu vois
sur des cv sont brandon si ce soir
fanatiques mes nuits sont pas fanatiques
parce que c'est révélateur de d'un
milieu social ou du social c'est
toujours moi je connais des kevin qui
sont oui mais tu as caution très
remaniée oui mon vieux c'est pas la
majorité du genre kevin gameiro qui
donnent aujourd'hui bon mes mails et
brandon et tous les gens qui appellent
leurs enfants des prénoms des gens des
feux de l'amour etc
c'est significatif ça veut dire quelque
chose après on peut s'en c'est
pas grave mais en tout cas c'est assez
important
après est-ce qu'on veut s'intégrer est
ce qu'on peut et est-ce qu'on doit c'est
un autre débat mais c'est pas pour les
mondiaux de dire que un prénom curieux
appel la curiosité et que c'est comme un
étendard
on revendique quelque chose quand on
s'appelle canton simple quand on appelle
son enfant de jeunes ça veut dire que on
est clairement américains ou d'origine
anglo saxonne et qu'on veut que ça se
sache
donc pourquoi est ce que quand c'est un
américain ont dit ah bah oui tiens
s'appelle jeunes effectivement vous dis
pas abriter racisme zoo qui il se montre
comme américain donc effectivement soit
on a un prénom de d'une certaine origine
acceptons que ce soit l'étendard de
cette origine et puis c'est tout est ce
que c'est normal de dire j'ai des propos
là c'est pour ça que je vais vous lire
pour que ce soit très très clair ce
n'est pas sorti des propos non mais les
premiers plus ou moins 3 non mais
pourquoi serait-ce a été coupée alors
c'était quoi ça a été compté si c'était
vraiment quelque chose de normal que
dans une jupe à ce que ce qu'est ce que
dans une discussion de presse
mon père a tout à fait le droit de dot
dans une discussion dire des choses et
finalement de dire que finalement ces
suites juridiques sur ça démontre ça
démontre que non j'aimerais juste les
lire ses propos pour ça comme ça je dois
puisque d'après ils ont tourné sur le on
a vu des images avec ses propos il dit
c'est c'est votre prénom qui est une
insulte à la france
la france n'est pas une terre vierge
c'est une terre avec une histoire avec
un passé et les prénoms incarne
l'histoire de la france excusez moi mais
alors ça moi je dis qu'ils sont des
propos racistes parce qu'on est en train
de dire que quand on ne s'appelle
mustapha ben mustapha c'est une forme et
une nation mais là c'est vrai que la loi
de la voie du bien d'avoir changé mais
bon depuis sept ans on nous donner des
prénoms que vous aimez que ceux qui
étaient dans les calendriers we know me
fit un temps patrice verdon non mais il
n'ya de db juste en anecdotes qui avait
quelqu'un qui voulait appeler son enfant
c'était souhaitait des africains
boulevard périphérique parce que dans en
afrique on peut appeler les enfants du
lieu de la fête
boulevard boulevard périphérique nantais
refusé à l'état civil français
mais pour autant il ya un flux intense
comprenez peut-être dans les calendriers
mais maintenant on prend plus dans les
calendriers il ya une liberté
il ya des gens qui viennent vivre en
france je ne vois pas pourquoi on
pourrait on leur dit que c'est une
insulte à la france d'avoir un prénom
qui est un prénom qui n'est pas dans le
calendrier je trouve que c'est moi je ne
comprends pas qu'un cas 15 mg ou reçoit
toujours sur les plateaux de télévision
d'autres abandonnent le débat parce que
selon moi qu'il faut censurer par surgir
est certaine je rappelle quand même que
cette séquence n'est pas passé à la
télévision
donc oui mais ça veut tout ce problème
est juste à tomber non mais
mona ce traumatisme c'est quasiment du
domaine privé puisque ce n'est pas
diffusée que 20 jeux comme si j'allais
chez toi en disant un b 1er chez toi un
dîner tu as dis ça mais si on était dans
le cadre d'un dîner ce n'est pas passé à
la télévision donc c'est au vu de sa vie
et m'annonce aussi qui est en fait on
pour sa vie mais arrêtez ces procès
d'anciens maintenant ce n'est pas passé
d'accord non mais c'est vrai que ça des
prix d'alsace et patrick allemand tant
que ça va pas été diffusés certain temps
mais ça a été diffusé parce que
scénariste non mais c'est un peu importe
les raisons ça n'a pas été diffusée donc
ne discutons pas des faits ne sont pas
des qui sont pas utilisables
ben oui je veux dire si non alors bon
bah là où va-t-on j'ai pas écouté la
séquence par contre ça fait tellement
leur personnage de la séquence des
personnes à la démission que ça fait
beaucoup parler ces blocs on est en
train de commenter
en revanche ce que j'entends là tout de
suite c'est finalement moi j'avais pas
compris ça comme ça je pense qu'on doit
être très nombreux l'a pas l'avoir
compris comme ça j'avais pas compris que
le prénom et l étendard moi je pensais
que c'était ça pouvait être tout
simplement affectif c'est à dire on peut
porter le prénom de ses ancêtres le
prénom de quelqu'un qu'on apprécie le
prénom de bas d'une personne que j'ai
été et mais en l'occurrence par les
parents puisque nous finalement le
prénom comme le tien jean-charles tulle
a subi honte la honte la donner oui moi
on m'a donné le lien mais je veux croire
que mes parents m'ont donné pour de très
bonnes raisons
et ça suffit les bonnes raisons qu'ont
eu mes parents de me donner ce prénom et
tous les parents du monde de donner le
prénom qu'ils veulent ça me suffit
maintenant il aurait fallu le décliner
en fonction de l'étendard qu'on veut
représenter en fonction de la
nationalité qu'on veut incarner mais
jusque
moi je suis pas un féru d'histoire
probablement que zemmour on est un
beaucoup plus que moi mais pas tant que
ça est-ce que les caisses que le
calendrier existe depuis depuis la nuit
des temps
est-ce que les prénoms qu'on veut
évoquer merengue de chrétiens j'imagine
qu'ils étaient il n'existait pas
forcément avant l'ère chrétienne
ou alors je j'ai pas compris le
calendrier chrétien apprécié à la date
de départ dont la teneur chrétienne date
d'un petit moment il va bien à l'échelle
à l'échelle humaine
j'ai tendance à prendre un peu de recul
et il ya un peu de rigueur à l'échelle
humaine 2011 s'est pas non plus
excessifs mais sans vouloir en soûlard
sans vouloir entrer dans cette technique
c'est de dire que d'abord je comprends
pas bien cette histoire franchement je
la comprends pas hormis de croire que
c'est effectivement pour faire le buzz
mais il est beaucoup plus intelligent
que ça parce que faut pas lui retirer sa
il l'est dans qui effectivement cette
idée selon laquelle une personnalité
n'est plus un citoyen comme on me l'a
appris moi un citoyen avec les valeurs
d'une république basée sur cette
citoyenneté qu'on veut incarner et les
valeurs qu'on qu'on défend tout ceci
maintenant ce serait soumis à un prénom
à une origine indélébile et qui ne
serait pas changeantes
quand on reprend l'histoire de tous les
émigrés qu'on appelait leurs enfants du
nom de leurs parents leurs grands
parents
tous n'avaient pas en tête de rester
forcément en france et de se dire que
j'appelle mon enfant plus de 20 et je
vais rester ad vitam
il ya des gens qui sont tout simplement
pour travailler dans ce pays
à une époque où c'était possible à une
époque où on aurait été demandée ils
sont venus ils ont fait leurs enfants il
n'en savait absolument rien d'un projet
personnel et on va pas reprocher à tout
le monde d'avoir des projets à la
zemmour d'avoir des projets à la jean
charles d'avoir des projets où chacun
devrait porter son étendard de reprocher
c'est le sens qu'on ne sait pas en
l'occurrence de toute façon vous savez
on ne reproche rien à personne mais je
te laissera
ces jeux le pire et on fait si l'oiseau
alors je dis ça parce que vous disiez
vous je dis moi mais je me fous de ce
que dit zemmour mais moi ce qu'on veut
simplement dire c'est que lui c'est
peut-être plus facile de s'intégrer au
lycée que le choix d'un prénom est assez
important et après on dit voilà on sait
très bien que c'est ont su à cordes
il ya des gens qui en plus de sentiments
que de politique n'y a pas que
dépolitiser il n'y a pas que des
intellos il n'y a pas que des gens qui
conceptualise autour du prénom c'est
juste affecte mon enfant va s'appeler
comme mon grand-père j'y tiens j'en veux
mais il ya aussi beaucoup de gens
d'origine étrangère qui ont baptisé
enfin donné comme nom de fait avec des
prénoms qui sont tout à fait français
quelque part les imagine zidane
justement zinedine s'appelle inédit mais
il ay là il a appelé ses enfants et des
prêts trop tout à fait français
les français lui aussi non
les affaires d'argent deuxième point la
question de savoir si parce que je
m'appelle mustapha je suis pas intégré
assimilés est-ce que ça vous a posé des
voyants dans les valeurs d'une
république de sallèles ici blablabla la
question est les seuls hommes jeu est ce
que ça vous a posé mais n'ont jamais
parce que d'abord c'est sur ma gueule
que ça se voit donc que je m'appelle
mustapha à la limite il y en a il ya un
bénin qui s'appelle alexandre maintenant
toute la première question que les gens
se posent et je comprends pas pourquoi
un prénom qui s'appelle comme alexandre
alors qu'il a une gueule de beurre donc
à un moment donné ce qui frappe quand
même les gens quand on l'est c'est là
qu'elle rencontre au premier au premier
abord on n'a pas encore commencé à
prendre c'est son prénom c'est juste que
on voit bien que tber là-dessus il n'y a
pas trop de ya pas de débat et c'est
tant mieux ça se voit c'est comme ça que
je le porte
mon écran à mai
le prénom n'a jamais posé de preuves de
problèmes à la limite il est il est
associé à la personnalité et à sa fille
ce voile associés à ce que je suis à ce
que je représente
mais la vraie question encore une fois
c'est celle lancée est ce qu'on peut
vivre ensemble avec des prénoms
différents des cultes
on en revient toujours à la même
question avec des prénoms différents des
cultures différentes des origines
différentes
la réponse est oui sauf qu'on n'en prend
pas beaucoup
franchement le chemin en communautarise
en autant et je parle pas simplement des
communautés communauté est plus qu'un
mais on est tellement chacun dans nos
couloirs on est chacun dans nos dans nos
souvenirs sont nos communautés facebook
on va chercher tous les gens qui nous
ressemblent
bah ouais mais à un moment donné on va
se sur la gueule pour le prénom
pour d'autres raisons
mais c est vrai qu il ya d y avait mais
il ya des prénoms qui incite aux
communes de taille pourrait on parler de
l'histoire des prénoms mais moins
zemmour je crois qu'on a eu on a eu un
débat sur le premier livre ici moi je me
suis emballé ce livre pour les 800 tr 8
mai mais la pire des choses avec
lesquelles je suis d'accord avec ces
mots tu peux pas brûler ni un livre ni
un mec sous prétexte qu'il a dit une
grosse connerie comme celle là d'autant
plus que c'est une connerie à mes yeux
ça visiblement ça ne l'est pas à ses
yeux ces lieux parce que maintenant on
les refait une émission dans laquelle
est il qu'elle vivait lui disais mais
c'est très con excusez-vous puis on
passe à autre chose face aux lions
anglais et lors des pc mais avec rachida
dati qui s'appelait zahia voilà que
reprocher son frère ce que je trouve
dommage c'est que moi j'aimais bien les
zemmour de chez ruquier parce que bon il
a des idées qui sont très loin des
miennes mais je trouvais qu'ils
mettaient du piment c'est quelqu'un
d'intelligent c'est quelqu'un qui a une
culture
et puis c'est quelqu'un ça on peut pas
lui reprocher qu'il ya vraiment un amour
de la france
mais le problème c'est que cet amour de
la france il est maintenant depuis
peut-être de trois ans devenu une tare
de détestation de tout ce qui n'est pas
la france de tous deux sans exclure les
autres dom
de l'idée qu'il se fait de la france
parce que là encore il faudra pour cela
il faut exclure tout ce qui tout ce qui
me fera tout ce qui est ailleurs la
bande et lisa sion le capital in les
femmes le fait 8 bis 9
et puis et puis c'est avoir une vision
fixies de la france c'est à dire c'est à
dire que maman la france s'arrête dans
quelque chose explication le supplice
beauzile s'est figé pour figer ça n'a
cessé contraire à toutes les lois de
l'histoire et des civilisations par des
tendances
il incarne encore une fois des courants
de pensée par ils vont ils en parlent
mais n'entend pas impunément
c'est pas 3 400 à 1000 exemplaires de
livres
c'est cette grosse pourquoi il est suivi
mais c'est vrai qu'il ya moins ya
quelque chose que je retrouve chez lui
de près de nantes très très fort c'est
l'intérêt général avant l'intérêt
particulier donc me parlez pas des
femmes c'est un sujet que je veux pas
aborder me parlez pas des gays me parlez
pas des bété ne parlait pas des immigrés
c'est l'intérêt général et l'intérêt
général suprême c'est la france les
français on verra après donc louis xiv
pour la france a du bon bain à part pour
la france a du bon grande la socgen est
dit dans le vestiaire et on respire
russie est un acteur important
rousseau et et des gens qui ont eu des
des courants de pensée qu'on reçoit plus
que voltaire est en effet elle est
peut-être mais on sent chez lui qui a
dit il ya des personnages et pétanque
pettinger rôle mais sur le jeu ont
construit la france les français on
verra après quelle que soit la couleur
tuez les tous et et l'on reconnaîtra les
siens au succès des formules j'en fais
le
la question de la présence dans le média
ce qu'il faut ce qu'il faut l'invité ce
qu'il faut censurer vous disiez moi je
n'inviterai pas je pense pas qu'il
serait l'invité dans les maisons mais je
pense que s'il ya une espèce que je
trouve ces derniers temps de paresse
intellectuelle des journalistes qui
finalement bon c'est pas bien grave
variable on va couper puis on n'en parle
pas et met ça sur le tapis et puis parce
qu'ils vendent parce qu'il vend des
livres elle c'est le fait de faire un
peu le fond il faut quand même ça je
trouve que ça manque un peu de
d'applications un peu de sens d'éthique
de valeur et on peut pas laisser des
gens dire tout et n'importe quoi je
trouve ça extrêmement j'étais
extrêmement choqué par ce qu'il a dit
même si sap a été passé à la télé mais
comme c'est passé il partout sur
internet tout le monde l'a entendu
donc voila moi je pense que c'est non
faut arrêter de faire en sorte que les
gens entendent des paroles comme ça
c'est pas mais il est publié
vous allez voir une politique et ses
bouquins physiquement il a des éditeurs
et publie ses livres
s'il ya des médias qui sont aussi
nationaliste et que lui va très bien qui
est qu'il y ait accepté un certain débat
et que les gens ne soient pas tous de
votre avis non ils ont droit de
s'exprimer ou c'est fini a eu une police
de la pensée mais lui il pense pas
bloqué c'est con c'est clairement un
truc classique et moi ne ne passe pas
son temps à attaquer absatou dit bon
donc si vous êtes en train de dire
faudrait pas d'invité jeune que moi je
pense que plus jean sarkozy
on habitait bourg ici vous vous déplacez
sûr que tout ça se fasse dans le respect
de la foi c'est tout un jeu vidéo kane
bien quotidien qui ne vient pas moi je
viens viens je dis mais encore une fois
je les lui enfin pas le dernier mais je
les lui ai dit oui certains français
mais si j'ai pas écouté non plus ce qui
a été dit mais de bruit autour
mais si je viens mais voilà c'est vrai
que moi je rejoins florence sur un point
il ya une vraie paraissent on est
d'accord il tue la dune à bien exprimer
cela étant lui force justement à
débattre force au débat force à être à
apporter des arguments parce qu'après
tout la porte les siens terre que lui
quand il y effectivement un prénom c'est
un étendard et je considère que la
france ait perdu si tous les enfants
paraissaient bien d'autres on est une
insulte c'est pas née tendance à parler
de ceux qui n'étaient pas dans le
calendrier
ça va trop mais ça n'a même pas débattre
c'est juste donne envie de se lever
le propre d'un problème c'est toujours
pareil moi ça me fait penser à jean
marie le pen il ya une époque serre qui
a 30 ans moi je disais ce mec là il faut
que le débat est ce qu'il faudrait
invités à essayer
voilà on a dit il faut pas inviter les
aime et on voit que ça nous arrangerait
certain moment donné il ya une pensée
cette pensée elle existe
il ya des courants de pensée il ya des
gens qui pensent comme ça moi je pense
qu'il vaut mieux donc ils rament adolf
hitler folle invités mais adolf hitler
avant d'avoir le pouvoir mais c'est
fascinant
vous savez c'est la plante ça voudrait
dire que ça voudrait dire que mais non
l'affairé soit soit c'est les gars
soient celis east side by side qui a des
propos qu'on ne peut pas tenir les
pauvres va se retrouver pour deux ans
jusqu'au bout quoique proposées dont
trois passes les acteurs parce que c'est
ça que nous parce que je suis claire a
été élu c'est pas parce qu'il a fait des
plateaux de télé à l'époque et marine le
pen sera probablement élue aussi et
zemmour prendra peut-être un jour
comment dire le fameux prendra peut-être
éventuellement la présidence
tu avoues pouvait l'exclure mais son
idéologie la transmettra comme il y en a
d'autres
il yad'autres cure anti demi et ça passe
pas par les plateaux télé le mot de
godard qui disait la télévision
maintenant c'est peu un quart d'heure
pour hitler un quart d'heure pour les
juifs quant au concept
non mais c'est vrai c'est qu'il fait
c'est ya cet écueil le mois jeudi 9 h
j'adore comparer des beaux arts
samedi c'est vrai que dix ans vous venez
vous avez des télévisions américaines
vous vous voyez des nazis le face à des
huiles etc parce que vous êtes un dîner
alors évidemment la liberté de parole et
est totale il ya des propos qui
évidemment tombent sous le coup de la
loi il ya des choses qu'on ne peut pas
laisser dire on peut pas tout dire sur
un plateau sinon on peut laisser des
gens invités au souci de tenir des
propos pédophiles ou tenir des propos
naziste ou là on verse dans une extrême
qui est à boeing
voilà donc là il ya quand même une vidéo
qui est enfin là donc il ya des choses
qu'on peut pas laisser faire
en revanche par rapport à ce que dit
eric zemmour je partage complètement
l'effroi de ce qu'il a dit une insulte à
la france je trouve que c'est c'est
absolument grave mais comment dirais je
comment moi je trouve qu'il faut quand
même c'est quelqu'un qui représente un
courant de pensée et je ne crois pas
qu'on règle les problèmes en les testant
ou en faisant comme s'il n'existait pas
que quiconque soit au courant de pensée
encore une fois qu'ils vont beaucoup
appris qu'ils vont beaucoup voient là et
je pense que même les mêmes problèmes
que la famille le pen
moi je pense que ce genre de personnes
doivent être combattus de façon
démocratique à partir du moment où les
propos reste des propos qui même si il
suscite les froids ne sont pas des
propos qui tombent sous le coup de la
loi puisque là effectivement on engage
des poursuites
donc moi je pense qu'il faut les
combattre je pense que ces gens avec
lesquels mais voilà parce que là il faut
débattre
voilà des gens qui ont existé je pense
que et je trouve très regrettable
d'ailleurs qu'il n'y ait pas
suffisamment de deux parlementaires
front national par exemple à l'assemblée
et je trouve qu'ils sont
sous-représentées je trouve ça très
dommageable puisque finalement je pense
pas que la meilleure manière de les
combattre ces deux façons enfin c'était
de le faire or dehors du parlement lors
de nos représentants le problématique de
l'émission la dernière émission c'est
que il était venu pour présenter son
livre sophie et il a pris à partie une
chroniqueuse ce n'était pas du tout dans
le sens où c'est un peu le monsieur sait
qu'il est face à des chroniqueurs qui
chacun de nous attaquer personnellement
enfin le but du débat allait y aurait un
débat sur la problématique des pressions
s'exercent dans un débat si vous
commencez à attaquer quelqu'un mais je
suis d'accord c'est la politique qui est
un débat démocratique sur des idées moi
je suis d'accord qu'il faut bien
évidemment combattre zemmour par la
démocratie par des débats avec lui quoi
pas mais là en l'espèce sauf ces dérives
pas laisser passer ça je n'étais pas là
pour débattre sur les histoires de
prénoms gpac world
il ya quand même vous le disiez enfin
nous dire tu peux une sorte de
libération de la parole quand même en
quelques années c'est à dire que il ya
dix ans ou quinze ans je veux dire
personne n'aurait osé dire ça non
journalistes en effet c'est peut-être
c'est peut-être en mars et du pacs est
devenu bien dire il ya quand même une
libération de la parole et de la parole
bien l'extrême droite quand même
banny enfin l'emploi poe c'est p'tet
bien je ne sais pas mais pas partout
vous prenez la moitié des sketches de
coluche pas un seul ne pourrait être
créé à louis où les proches d'où il a
donc la parole elle s'est pas fait c'est
pas tellement libéré puis non non
attendez attendez guère de ces hausses
hier jean charest ya deux choses
il ya deux choses c'était il ya deux
mois quand vous dites que ce n'est pas
lié à ses dires aujourd'hui c'est vrai
que in opinion et c'est le cas ce qui se
passe dans le cas présent on parle et on
va tout de suite on menace tout de suite
de procès mais tout à fait mais c'est
bien quand ça c'est une chose ça c'est
une chose mais en même temps vous pouvez
pas nier que l'extrême droite a dit
béret sa parole et on dit aujourd'hui
des choses qu'on n'osait pas dire il ya
dix ans mais dépassant prime de
l'extrême droite la plage des papilles à
plus de liberté à la médina 36 gilbert
et bien pensante de chape de plomb
ddd des bien pensants qui font que de
création d'états et dès qu'on a une
pensée qui sort un tout petit peu du
cadre agréable on est bannie c'est à
dire que on n'a pas le droit d'être
contre l'europe
on va dire que zemmour est pas illégal
et non mais a tellement tout tout de
suite tu montes tout le monde tire à
boulet rouge or il faut il faut le
condamner il faut le dire les ordis
européens sont bannis des meilleurs
matchs et dire non parce que on ne peut
pas exprimer des idées des concerts un
petit peu d'écart sur ces énoncés
impliquent de natacha polony à la
tyrannie des minorités
minorité aurait pris le pas non non non
à chaque mot est un exemple frappant qui
nous vient des états unis il ya un des
dirigeants de facebook qui fait un
procès ou au patron de facebook parce
qu'il dit nous sommes plusieurs à ne pas
avoir chanté les louanges des démocrates
et on en à notre carrière a été stoppée
et la justice américaine ait le temps de
le reconnaître
effectivement dans cette note dans cette
bulle de bien pensants ce qui engendre
effectivement aux états unis de ceux ci
si on veut bosser dans les dents les
gaffes à google amazon facebook ou apple
eh ben il est bon ton les démocrates la
seule personne qui pourrait dire moi je
pas forcément démocratique c'est le type
il est éjecté il est pas reçu en dix ans
maintenant et c'est un mal pensants
voilà c'est tout j'ai en france c'est la
même chose
donc ça veut pas dire qu'on érige il ya
entre guise et les mal pensants entre
guillemets des civils et des vides alors
que cet argument clé japon les avocats
entendus quand même avec tout le monde
ce groupe est encore j'avais vu comme un
méchant or c'est le diable tout c'est
une horreur nous adorons pour servir de
parler ou lemay nommé sait où on est on
est même dans un débat c'est assez
bizarre on dit maintenant bien pensé
c'est nul
au nom de la liberté d'expression
il ya pensé c'est plutôt qu'on supporte
plus de laisser les bien pensants seul
sur un plateau on veut amener quelqu'un
qui pense maille pour montrer que celui
qui pense bien pense bien voilà et
surtout et surtout ses covenants ferrat
normes et qu ils différents simplement
si telle avance par son talent et le
enfin ce n'est contre l'europe j'entends
beaucoup de temps contre l'europe que de
gens pour l'europe dans les décomptes
des médias patrice si je peut inverser
les rôles
qu'est ce que vous pensez vous du
journaliste qui était sûr dans
l'émission qui n'a rien dit capa tue pas
aller au combat dans l'émission de
zemmour sur le plateau alors les autres
ardisson qui n'a pas pour pas le nommer
qui n'a pas un sou plus accrue qui n'a
pas ce qu'est ce que la raison décidé de
couper après l'émission mais pendant
l'émission il n'a rien dit là parce que
sa chroniqueuse et ingénue que hal après
l'émission il est allé un peu l'anglais
le clocher la tentative a pas de non
seulement il n'a pas soutenu mais elle
ne sera pas dans la prochaine émission
et je pense qu'ils font penser vous y
attendent aujourd'hui à rien il ya même
eu un coût un peu pas où ils expliquent
ils l'ont payé un peu à l'avancé parce
qu'elle est le problème avec les infos
va moi j'ai après je pense que dans
cette émission là il est animateur il
laisse la place je pense aux
chroniqueurs donc ça c'est une forme de
démission après ce qui me choque un peu
dans ses émissions c'est être immenses
et des émissions de bond je dis pas que
je dis pas qu'on on s'aime beaucoup
entre douba enfin on se déteste pas
danger répression faisant ses émissions
les bourses et des gens qui sont les
sacs ou des autres se détestent qua non
il ya une fausse eu complicité cocon
d'établissement dans cette émission le
rôle des religions je crois que les
passeports injuste dans cette émission
non bah oui on en fait pas ce plat mais
il va se passer ce genre de plat sans se
boucher le nez lui j'espère passer
puisque ça a été coupée mais non mais ça
dessine donc les sacs après c'est pour
ça qu'ils font des émissions
enregistrées
c'est justement pour couper tout ce qui
donne tout ce qui va pas donc vous
pouvez pas lui reprocher de pas faire
ton boulot puisque justement
mais puisque ça ne sort pas mais ça va
arrêter de parler de choses qui sont pas
dit
son boulot comme étudiant les salles
elle a dit même pas parce que quand tu
invites on sait qu'il est possible de
sortir ces jeunes d'essayer d'aller les
chercher et je comprends maintenant
c'est sa préface la théorie pour les
côtés de l'addition c'est de dire on
doit pouvoir aller s'exprimer toutes les
études de toutes les opinions
c'est à dire que je suis n'a pas à
choisir entre les opinions face de lui
il laisse les gens s'exprimer je crois
que ses fans ou qu'il n'a pas drôle de
penser quoi moi je pense que non mais sa
précocité par l'animateur de dire voilà
ce qu'il faut penser au poste c'est à
dire ne seront pas c'est d'aller le
rechercher pour dire parce que par
rapport à ce qu'il a exprimé sur le fait
que son prénom était une insulte de dire
à de rebondir dessus et d'aller d'aller
pousser le débat n'ont pas tous eu
presque le syndicat a été coupée bosser
pas eu d'accord mais ça s'est passé sur
le plateau corps sur le fait avec des
émissions audition s'est pas vanté
d'avoir fait quoi que ce soit non mais
je crois que je connais pas bien les
missions ne vaut pas ce qu'il y'a pas
grand monde qui leur garantit non plus
mais c'est juste de passer les plats
c'est pour ça que je perds mais j'ai
l'impression que j'ai l'impression que
il laisse la parole à chaque chroniqueur
face à l'invité lui lance les leurs
peuples et passe les plats quoi surtout
on va mettre la dégénérescence
artificiels sont tous et surtout que
c'est à brühl tant qu'à faire on laisse
faire parce que plus les bruillois
lorsque ça va tu as dit totalement réglé
maintenant il ya beaucoup d'émissions
maintenant on fait venir finalement la
société civile autour des plateaux où on
envie de les entendre
le casting est souvent fait pour faire
en sorte que ce soit pas effectivement
des gens qui s'apprécie mais qui
pourrait éventuellement se friter en
direct donc s'il ya une espèce de
concurrents sera facebook une
concurrence y est
maintenant je dis il n'y a pas
d'obligation non plus dans la vie à
regarder ardisson voilà puisqu'on en
parle et jean marie le pen qui doit
aller vers une expertise psychiatrique
alors elle n'irait pas wen à l'arrêt
battant c'est la loi c'est pas une
histoire mais c'est la loi c'est la loi
alors mac mini ou maxi briser la règle
juridique v que vous êtes obligé de vous
livrer à une expertise psychiatrique
quoi les auditive que les femmes
politiques seraient exclues des doigts
comme une année la nation même sujet
d'ailleurs c'est des propos qui
pourraient être aura six étaient
condamnables
là c'est l'image les montrait des images
qui est par définition condamnable dans
les deux cas il ya la joie dans ce pays
qui existent pour zemmour il parle de
lui et je trouve que les journées il
sait à l'heure c'est au tour tombé alors
d'abord on n'explique pas que que oui on
n'explique pas que c'est la loi qui
oblige se vivra cette expertise
psychiatrique d'une part puisque voilà
c'est la loi et d'autre part moi j'ai
entendu journée 6 et parce que au fond
marine le pen a instrumentalisé ça en
disant on veut on est dans la russie
soviétique comme dans les soviétiques ou
mettez les au présent elle utilise ça et
j'ai entendu hier des journalistes qui
terrasse et politiquement c'est bien
joué je trouve ça nul non c'est non
celle ci s'est tous les gens pour des
abrutis comme un succès et les yeux qui
vont pas intellectuellement intel
seulement nul mais acea toujours acquis
à val d'or elle s'adresse à six mais je
voudrais surtout vous avez voté pour moi
on va vous retirer votre vote on va te
faire de moi une folle on va faire
et l'allemand tomy et par mail au chaud
sur ce coup il a raison mais c'est
totalement abérrant geder quoi qu'on
pense de marine le pen c'est tout ce que
c'est une femme allez viens on va dire
mais ça sonne on dit qu'elle est folle
si on commence à prendre les hommes
politiques ou les femmes politiques de
premier plan et a commencé à les traiter
en dur balle à la procédure pénale
si la procédure de fastidieuses ils
considèrent adaptées démocratiquement
parce que quand on commence pas à
vouloir faire passer des tests
psychiatriques aux hommes ou femmes
politiques c'est qu'ils ne plaisent pas
à vitesse et magasins belges quick comme
ça mais ils sont comme par hasard c'est
une femme politique de premier plan que
les autres y en a deux qui des femmes
politiques donc la loi le prévoit dé
simplement dit des dispositions qui
permettent simplement donc de savoir si
la personne est tout simplement saine
d'esprit en fait c'est tout simplement
lui poser des questions pour savoir si
elle a un comportement sens et voilà
voilà
et lui présenter certains éléments donc
je vois pas ce qu'il y'a d'insultant il
s'agit pas de commencer à savoir quelle
est la relation qu'elle a avec son père
ou ce genre de choses qu'il a nommément
c'est inquiétant c'est absolue a duré
trois minutes la durée pas mieux que
d'ailleurs même pas les forces de
l'ordre ne vont pas aller
missive pour l'intimé d'aller devant le
psychiatre à elle peut ne pas y aller et
où il appartiendra au juge d'en tirer
des conséquences dont je pense pas
qu'ils aient du ragon séquence de sa
volonté de ne pas y aller l'internement
psychiatrique ou que ça la loi prévoit
que la personne peut refuser de faire
instrumentaliser cette procédure j smith
y ait une procédure judiciaire pas
savoir qu on est dans l'action
soviétique pas ça bien que instrumenté
sur la ligne je ne trouve pas normal que
on on demande à cette femme politique de
passer les plats typiques à ces médecins
côté droit alors quand il y avait
imaginé qu'on peut dire qu'il a la loi
et l'esprit de la loi que c'est bien
fait c'est d'une extrême délicatesse
mais je veux dire la même chose pour mes
le sud si on voulait faire passer un
test à mélenchon je trouvais ça débile
aussi s'il ya un moment où la démocratie
et le et le soutien d d d hector vaut
quelque chose si c'est moins sur la
transparence et de la tri moines des
hommes politiques qui vont de gouverner
c'est pas un test qu'on applique à tous
c'est facile mais maintenant didier dire
ça mais je suis encore ce truc est
merveilleux alors j'en suis sous tes
fesses aussi convaincu tout est fait on
marche et la rigueur on se croirait au
pire des années mitterrand tettey les
lieux où l'idée c'est de faire monter le
plus possible front national et là ça va
marcher note me regarder le dernier
sondage ils sont à égalité que sont les
siens à égalité avec l'élite en marche
edit je veux dire pourquoi de la mairie
se disent je vais dire pourquoi devrais
y aller parce que franchement les
soupçons de folie parce que cette
savante on parle de tests psychiatriques
il y aurait donc quelque chose de
pathologique chez elle voudrait rester
voudraient vérifier en tous les cas
mais finalement le soupçon s'est porté
il ya un petit moment nous alors du
débat où tout le monde a dit mais elle
est pété de la tête ça n'a donc
finalement pensé aller péter y en a
beaucoup qui bondit jeudi les p&t tout
court une réhabilitation
une réhabilitation est en route elle y
va et tout le monde dira mais à libé
mais super sage d'esprit auquel cas
pouvoir reprendre ses pires cci
qu'aucune différemment je ne l'imaginé
pas les dégâts que ça fait dans
l'opinion publique
j'ai dû 6e de presse y en a aucun qui
présente les termes de la loi il faut
même quand il faut quand même rappeler
aussi en plus il s'agit moi je vais
révéler moi j'ai un genou
j'ai trop même bienveillant les les
termes de la loi s'agit simplement de
voir si y'a pas d'abolition du
discernement
parce que s'il ya abolition du
discernement il n'y a pas de
responsabilités endossées par elle donc
c'est tout simplement de dire on vérifie
simplement si vous étiez saine d'esprit
si c'est pas le cas vous ne serez pas
responsable des actes que vous avez
commis enfin c'est quand même beau de
près on a des doutes
la deuxième chose c'est pas parce que
c'est pas son affaire c'est pas parce
qu'on va faire si catherine et
psychotique
elle va faire le test tout le monde sait
qu'elle est saine d'esprit on va dire
qu'elle est saine d'esprit terminée
l'affairé finit le front national en a
pris dix points dans les sondages
merveilleux très bonne idée c'est
parfait this is it is chercher ben oui
monsieur qu'est ce que vous dites pas ce
que vous dites que c'est des juges qui
font une action politique contre le
front national
ou alors que nous faisons c'est pour les
juges sont tenus et se prévoir sur des
listes explique catherine à peine de
nullité de la procédure
ils sont compétences liées non pas le
chant suis sûr que s'ils n'avaient pas
fait leur expertise psychiatrique elle
aurait dit vous n'avez pas fait l
expertise psychiatrique donc la
procédure est nulle et ben alors ému
raison d'ailleurs
alors il présenterait bien sûr ils sont
tenus de le faire complice parce que le
dernier quand même lui le délit c'est de
mettre des images particulièrement
violente que les mineurs que je
regardais il donc la loi dit c'est vrai
qu'on peut avoir des doutes sur
l'afrique a pris des factures de l'état
d'esprit des gens qui mettent l'egypte
s'est attaché à la loi est claire soit
la personne qui le fait doit faire cette
étiquette
revoyons nous dans quinze jours et
regardons les sondages non mais non mais
attendez
oui mais non exigence utilisent-ils
premier sas et c'est marine le pen elle
même et enfin les paroles 1
moi je trouve qu'en gérant les journées
je me dis c'est bien jouer politiquement
je trouve ça nul mais parce que c'est
considéré des gens comme des abrutis
bien complet mais mon émergents ne sont
pas leur job
patrice franke moi ce que je veux ce que
je sais que je perçois c'est qu'à chaque
fois que ces personnalités qui ont
beaucoup gens qui les suivent 36 font
une connerie ils en appellent à leurs
troupes et non pas aux références qui
nous unissent tous c'est uniquement mes
troupes ça s'appelle la le commandait la
commande idriss non non non c'est pas le
cas du tarif j'ai cherché le mot que ça
va me revenir mais il y en a d'autres
qui précède qu'ils attisent les hommes
politiques les hommes politiques d'une
part mais il y en a d'autres
un exemple tariq ramadan se fait prendre
dans le filet je pense que tu iras pas
le défendre suis là non
de la même façon si elle même se
défendre c'est le même principe
c'est volontairement je te propose celui
ci c'est le même principe il va se
tourner vers une communauté en disant en
stigmatisant voilà le mot que je
cherchais que je déteste mais qu'on
emploie beaucoup en stigmatisant en
étant la victime
et ça c'est pas tenable quand on est un
homme politique quand on les use chef
d'un courant au lycée palissy n'accuse
pas m ont fait une connerie sur ça je
reconnais ou pas mais j'en appelle pas
au peuple à la comment dire à la
victimisation qui fait que derrière ben
on entraîne des gens c'est ce qui mène à
la guerre si bien pour le coup donc tu
as raison mais ce n'est pas normal
qu'elle le fasse on voulait combattre
ouais les images pédopornographiques en
montrant des images pédopornographiques
pour expliquer que c'est pas bien et
c'est l'excellent à goutte et vous voyez
que c'est choquant voilà on a changé de
débat là on parle pas de ce qu'a fait
marine le pen on parle d'eux en plein de
deux expertises psychiatriques
oui cette expertise mais l'événement
politique c'est les clarisses peu c'est
l'expertisé psychiatrique elle expliqué
d'une manière qui fait qu'on oublie
aussi ce qui lui est reproché est ce qui
lui est reproché c'est quand même
extrêmement la cité c'est qu'avec deux
de deux hommes et femmes de loi de la
présomption d'innocence aussi balayé
jean sarda taxer la vente après année
ils étaient même expliqué que cette
procédure était non
le jeune fille sur 100 qui sans qu'on
lui reproche il paye là que j'en parle
mais tous les deux une avocate est un
homme heureux
à travers sa vie c'est comme s'il avait
déjà condamné à 12 ans d'attendre un
juge pour savoir que ce qu'elle fait
elle est contraire au code pénal vins de
provence le coach est d'avis que nous
sommes à relayer des images violence
extrême elle lâché c'est contraire à la
loi
elle sera condamnée on n'a pas besoin
d'attendre la décision du juge des
raccourcis c'est très bien je sais que
c'est pas la défaite c'est quoi c'est
quoi les faits jean charles oui du
régime
c'est quoi diffusion d'image oui oui
d'image bah oui mais ce n'est pas de
costard le français alors que des biens
vont pouvoir regarder des images des
sons des années par ailleurs c'est ce
qu'on aura droit est ce qu'on aura droit
à un débat est-ce qu'on en vient pas du
tout vous avez condamné s'est dit c'est
terminé
on essaye d'expliquer pourquoi une
expertise psychiatrique qui se délient
pouffer évident entre pénale ceci je ne
suis pas le juge le juge me confirmera
dans mon propos parce que on injurie si
l effet il ya la loi on peut faire la
qualification juridique bon voila j'ai
passé autre petite chanson un petit à
petit déclic on va parler de madame
hidalgo ya ce clip qui qui était financé
par la mairie de paris qui s'appelle pas
pipi dans paris je regardais un petit
extrait ça vaut c'est un peu pitoyable
[Musique]
jeudi
papy doit pas rien c'est alors ça sape à
côté d'une somme énorme vos comptes
révèle le parisien mais commencer dès
que vous avez regardé quelques images
vous en pensez quoi ça consiste moi je
crains en effet pervers parce que
j'imagine les parisiens garder ça sur
leur smartphone dans la rue épicé c'est
derrière les opposer rhinois on est
d'accord mais c'est vrai que le sujet
quand même important c'est que tous les
gens qui viennent à la capitale mais
nous on le dit également pour y aller
c'est vrai que c'est ça c'est souvent
lié à ces pro a c'est à le manger de la
propreté a baissé à 2 1 non mais mais ce
frère c'est vrai que c'est vrai ce mille
euros et c'est vrai que je ne sais pas
comment j'aurais pu amener la campagne
publicitaire sur un sujet pareil enfin
celui-ci on est d'accord il est à chier
on peut dire deuxième formé de pisser
sur un rat à paris de toute façon donc
on pousse un pater porcherie c'est vrai
qu'il ya des nouvelles appellent les
urines trottoirs directeur de petit box
rouge très identifiable qui met dans les
deux zones ont passé quatre ou cinq fois
c'est assez expérimental qui sont posées
dans des quartiers où les fêtards où les
gens ont souvent tendance à aller se
soulager donc les riverains ils ont tout
à fait raison ils en ont ras-le-bol
donc il se baisse de 2 du riz noir mais
qui est bien évidemment
réservé aux hommes oui alors défunt je
ne peuvent pas y aller d'où la fureur
des buts
d'où la flower une association féministe
qui est à les démonter un nury trottoir
en plein coeur de paris en disant c'est
scandaleux de faire 10 rue des murs etr
des mesures et trottoirs interdit aux
femmes enfin pas accessibles aux femmes
donc pas duré trottoir du tout fan là le
féminisme ou alors il faut que les
femmes apprennent à faire pipi d'eau
boueuse et machine qu'est devant pia un
petit instrument qui est vendu dans les
pays d'amérique latine qui permet aux
femmes de faire plier debout mais qui
sur mineurs ou les hommes font des
billets à 6 puis voilà oui mais un grand
déballage fait pas pour qu'elles
puissent s'asseoir tout simplement fait
quoi l'idée de vous la le faire je le
ferai plus tôt en mars
non c'est se retenir
voilà le le tracé comme premier pas
revenue et tu trouves des trois étoiles
est pas là en traversant là on notera
l'arrivée les urines mois après où les
sanisettes
je sais pas mais c'est encore lui en
tout cas c'est gratuit grâce à lui les
communes et des problèmes de côté non il
ya toujours autant du riz noir de 2,2
sanisettes dans paris alors ça c'est un
détail cette ligue mais évidemment ça se
pose la question de anne hidalgo de la
maire de paris avec la démission de son
premier adjoint bruno julliard qui dit
voilà elle gouverne tout seul les coûts
de personnes
comment vous là et c'est vrai il ya
plein de prendre la marée il ya en effet
les vélib gestion catastrophique puisque
je crois que la baisse de fréquentation
de vélib a baissé de 80% les autolib qui
marchent plus je ne marche plus la
propreté en question les voitures qui ne
peuvent plus circuler il ya un tas de
problèmes qui s'accumulent sur le bureau
de la maire de paris mais eux
effectivement ça s'annonce assez assez
mal alors après elle a quand même une
chance inouïe c'est que comme pour
l'instant personne non identifiée en
face voilà elle suppose qu'elle est au
plus bas et pas très bas dans les
sondages elle peut ne pas être bonne
elle peut de voilà bon mais et conserve
donc il reste encore deux ans le
conserve
hélas toutes ses chances mais ce qui est
très symptomatique emblématique d'anne
hidalgo c'est la photo c'est parce que
lentement en régie ou que tel recevait
en tant que maire de paris la reine
d'angleterre
on la voit avec un conseiller ou on peut
dire larbins derrière qui tient le
parapluie parce qu'il pleut pour
protéger nidal go et à côté la reine
d'angleterre son parapluie
et hélas est tout à fait emblématique de
dollars de la chose avec laquelle kkr
yeux
quelqu'un qui arriverait de la vue et on
lui dit c'est ça la semaine dernière
avec des années maintenant il aurait dix
ans les ans un vieux maire a pris cette
image n ai absolument emblématique
d'anne hidalgo
tout est dit dans cette tendance était
moche parce que elle aurait pu et sur le
four de la regarder car sur le fond de
la politique c'est un manque de vision
du ciel elle sort un livre qui s'appelle
respirer dans lequel elle défend
évidemment son bilan et notamment
notamment sa lutte contre l'automobile à
paris
en disant ça serait ça serait un
scandale absolu de rendre par exemple
les voies sur berge à l'automobile mais
ce que ce que anne hidalgo a totalement
oublié puisque elle n'a jamais travaillé
ailleurs que dans la politique ou dans
l'administration etc
c'est que paris est quand même fait de
gens qui travaillent de restaurateurs
qui ont besoin de se faire livrer de
gens qui ont besoin des deux à des
rendez-vous de il ya une population qui
travaille encore qu'il n'y a pas encore
été rejetée de paris vu les coûts donc
ces gens là ont quand même besoin de se
déplacer besoin d'exister que c'était
mais pour inna di pour anne hidalgo
visiblement ces gens n'existent pas donc
peu importe plus de voitures plus de
majorité de gens qui n'ont pas d'enfant
et qui n'ont pas de voiture non plus on
dit souvent que les politiques n'ont pas
de courage et qui vont dans le sens de
ce que les gens souhaitent pour être
réélu finalement elle roulait
l'égreneuse pour ne pas être réélus
quand une base en tant que fils il en
charge finit finalement a fait tout pour
ne pas être aimé par contre elle a une
conviction chevillée à l'autre voire de
dire mon combat c'est là c'est pas la
voiture
c'est probable la pulsion est là pour la
survie financière et celle dont revoyons
la mort à syrte et dans son exemple la
mobilité dans son ensemble ainsi attaque
je ne dis pas qu'elle fait bien moi j'y
habite pas à paris j'y vais de temps en
temps mais même en bécane tu ne circule
pas tellement cette venue compact mais
je prends l'homme politique la femme
politique qui allait finalement
bâle a du courage j'entends jean temps
j'entends que de mauvaises choses la
concernant et pourtant elle s'y accroche
ça doit vous entendre tous elle doit
bien se rendre compte de ce qui
s'accumulent au delà des poubelles des
dossiers et des problèmes avec son
numéro un qu'est parti
récemment bruno julien que lui la portée
du messie mais ça c'est encore un
épiphénomène serre qu'elle l'a écouté
pendant des années il a dû se rapprocher
de macron parce que je ne me soucie pas
les lancer depuis longtemps lui il a dû
se rapprocher des macros ni celle du
savoir la claquer son clash et ils sont
séparés ou c'est de la politique c'est
un épiphénomène mais moi je parle de la
femme politique année contre l on peut
se bat et dernièrement et dernière chose
pardon totalement levé son suffrage
indirect fait qu'elle aura toutes ses
baronnies qui peut être probablement
seront réélus chacun dans leur
département j'allais dire dans leur
arrondissement et que ça lui reviendra
au final par voie indirecte
donc elle n'est pas finie c'est vrai que
c'est un électorat qui fait que chaque
guerre des réactions elle aime moins de
voix que jusqu'au bout risque la même
chose je suis tout à fait d'accord avec
mustapha mais ce que je ne comprends pas
c'est son système c'est de dire
effectivement luttant contre la
pollution mettons des mobilités douces
et elle se retrouve ou sur les vélib
on a un problème il ya plus d'autolib va
falloir gérer d'histoire parce que
bloquer les véhicules pas que ça vienne
dans paris pourquoi pas mais derrière il
faut du vélo il faut de la voiture
électrique il faut et là tout d'un coup
on est sur un moment et c'est ça qui est
compliqué pour elle c'est que gère le
lopin de dominer sigean compter le
problème c'est aussi parce qu'il ya
quand même un peu des choses parce
qu'ils aient une rupture de marché enfin
mais juridiquement ça c'est comme ça je
pense que j'ai bien géré le long terme
quand nous protège ma bagnole c'est
demain matin que je peux pas leur cô té
lé sur un combat long terme c'est quand
même le propre des politiques de nous en
est quand même bien de vision plus
ajoutez carrière vous disent ils pas on
n'entend pas beaucoup les autres mais
personne ne remet vraiment en cause ce
combat là mais la droite non plus car
ses conséquences comme en cause c'est la
façon de faire c'est tout oui c'est
peut-être des priorités c'est ce qu'il
faut par d'avoir faire plus de
transparence aux abords de supprimer la
voiture de service et puissent merci ce
manque de vision par exemple d'avoir
viré de caux et ses vélib en reprenant
une nouvelle société qui à l'évidence
actuellement incapable il ya un an et
demi de retard sur l'installation des si
la loi voilà il fallait should of fini
juste on peut quand même aller dans une
boîte et essayer qu'au bout d'un an et
demi et quand même les vélos fonctionne
mais ça c'est une jour paca mais là où
je parle de problèmes de vision c'est
que on en était au mans où les décisions
ont été prises on est arrivé l'émergence
de ce nouveau cette nouvelle façon de
faire du vélo qui est le free float
inglés des vélos qui ne sont plus
attachés à des bornes essais de vélos
par castro c'était une catastrophe pour
la première société cake à déposer le
bilan mais les autres fonctionnent très
bien il ya des trottinettes en free
flottille des scooters en free floating
des vélos free pratique il serait
dangereux de circuler dans paris dans la
vision du maire de paris de ces équipes
qui n'a même pas
en visant à supporter quand même très
forte dès lors c'est à dire que le
l'état d'aider autolib été
catastrophique cftc dégueulasse pour des
voitures
les vélib qui était absolument enfin les
vélib qui n'était pas fondée dans des
attachés dans des bornes et n importe ou
cassés enfin tout ça c'est vrai qu'à
aussi une incivilité terrible et puis
enfin les restrictions sont immédiates
sûr que quand tu fermes une rue tu la
fermes demain matin par contre les
solutions qui a peu apporté elle peut
pas venir le surlendemain donc les
solutions qu'elle propose prennent du
temps
par contre les restrictions elles sont
immédiates et c'est ça qui se
télescopent c'est sa vision long terme
avec arme ou nous qui avons besoin de
nos mobilité au jour le jour et les
solutions qu'elles apportent qui prend
du temps pour penser que ce n'est pas
perdu pour elle quoi pour moi ça ne
l'est pas parce que c'est propre encore
une fois les parisiens qui vont voter il
ya beaucoup de gens qui ont envie d'une
ville bat plus plus respirable
probablement hic c'est quand même
l'essentiel mais on termine pas là
peut-être la phrase
des manuels macro et horticulteurs qui
pourraient être employées j'ai vu ça par
le conseil général des yvelines puisque
pierre bédier veulent engager que pour
une mission d'encadrement au service des
espaces verts
c'est dire que voilà un type qui
voulaient tranquillement profiter de
république puis de 2,2 ce qu'il allait
toucher du chômage et le bec tous bords
ne propose du boulot à varennes celui de
traverser la rue dans la phrase du
président ma qui on dénie option pas
choquant britannique passe son temps à
dire que les que les politiques
pratiquent une certaine langue de grille
et là il s'adresse directement à
quelqu'un de belle façon avec du courage
couac est bien le courage en politique
et surtout parce que j'adore dans cette
méthode macron c'est que il a eu le
mérite de lancer le débat c'est à dire
que depuis cette petite phrase tout le
monde ne parle plus que des milliers
d'emplois qui ne sont pas
oui c'est qui semblait hier on en parle
de plus en plus chaque fois des
reportages entre les deux emplois qui
sont offerts et les sur toutes les
radios tout l'été sans arrêt des
reportages dans tel était le secteur
demain voilà on a du mal à embaucher et
là il manque 200 mille deux cent mille
personnes à hesmond 90000 excellent donc
il a relancé le délire déjà très bien
une dame qui habitait rue pigalle qui a
dit j'ai traversé la rue j'ai trouvé du
travail mais maintenant j'ai un peu mal
au derrière
enfin bon c'est une émission que je
serais pas choqué au battle get bain par
la formule par la formule on ne peut
être que choqué c'est parce a du courage
la ja marcquois pour le coup il est là
il est il incarne le président il est
entouré de plein de plein de
personnalités autour de lui et il
s'adresse à quelqu'un qui dit je veux
être horticulteurs et le 10 mai à temps
si tu veut du boulot le mec n'a pas dit
qu'ils venaient du boulot il voulait
être horticulteurs qui a peut-être ya
peut-être une manière de dire comme
probablement que tu peux changer de voie
et probablement que tu pourrais te
renseigner sur d'autres formulations
mais là ces gens moi je suis capable de
trouver du taf quand je d'ailleurs il
avait préféré qu'il fasse comme tous les
hommes politiques devaient moi votre cas
unique
mieux parce qu'il faut conserver la
formule est choquante mais enfin il n'a
pas juste dit cette formule de façon
lapidaire il ya tout un discours qu'il a
dit au tour
et si on leur vie john on se rend compte
que finalement le propos est assez banal
et convenu qu'il n'ya vraiment pas de
quoi il c'est vrai que le l'accent sur
un sur un problème que vous soulevez
voilà alors on va être obligé de se
quitter thierry barbeau dell propose que
tous les chroniqueurs de l'émission
passe une expertise psychiatrique et il
était un problème
après peut-être faire passer une
expertise aux experts merci merci en
tout cas tous les cas merci jean
baptiste du club mustapha larbaoui
florence rey s'est dit choqué et jean
charles lajoie ni et à très vite pour un
nouveau prof
[Musique]